[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pendant deux mois au
printemps dernier les français ont été
confinés chez eux
comment et pourquoi cette mesure
qualifiée de moyenâgeuse mais en réalité
totalement inédite dans l'histoire de
l'humanité at elle été prise par le
président de la république est pourquoi
le 17 mars
pourquoi pas plutôt le sociologue henri
bergeron a des réponses à toutes ces
questions avec olivier borraz patrick
castel et françois dedieu il a mené une
enquête à chaud auprès des acteurs de la
crise ils publient aujourd'hui que vîmes
19 une crise organisationnel aux presses
de sciences po qui éclaire d'un jour
nouveau ce qui se passe dans notre pays
depuis un an
mais commençons tout de suite par notre
époque comment comme c'est la tradition
dans cette émission qu'est ce qui
caractérise ce début de xxième siècle
voici l'image que vous avez choisi henri
bergeron
elle est derrière moi que
représente-t-elle elle représente
certainement la prise en compte avec une
acuité beaucoup plus prononcée des
effets sur tout sur une une toute une
série dimension des effets des mesures
qui ont été prises pour lutter contre
l'épidémie elle même donc là on voit une
personne qui est penché sur son
ordinateur qui sort certainement
peut-être de l'hôpital où kate un
soignant il ya de la boisson s'est
passée la boisson alcoolisée pourvoi sas
ça reflétait à la fois là des
conséquences sociales psychique
économique donc certainement des
conséquences en terme sanitaire qu'on
aura à la suite de cette période très
dure et très dur aussi par les mesures
que l'on a prises et bien commençons
tout de suite
[Musique]
henri bergeron faisait deux sociologues
vous êtes directeur de recherche au cnrs
et je les dis avec olivier beaud rase
patrick castel et françois dedieu qui
sont tous sociologue vous publiez que
8,19 une crise organisationnel aux
presses de sciences po alors une crise
organisationnel ça signifie qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'une crise unikin il faut
l'inscrire dans une série d'autres
crises que ce soit la crise des missiles
de cuba en 62 la tempête de 99 les
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 la
canicule de l'été 2003 où l'ouragan
katrina en 2005 qui ont tout provoquer
des crises organisationnel alors c'est
quoi pour vous une crise organisationnel
alors vous avez raison de souligner que
la tendance de nos gouvernements un peu
partout en europe et dans les pays
occidentaux c'est de singulariser la
crise la tempête de 99 finalement c'est
une tempête exceptionnelle qu'on pouvait
pas prévoir la le laconique 19 aussi
sera une crise exceptionnelle à chaque
fois on isole et singularise une crise
et on s'empêche de penser les éléments
qui sont communs à ces crises en dépit
du fait qu'elles sont d'une nature très
différente et notamment s'empêche de
penser les éléments communs de gestion
de ces crises et notamment les éléments
communs de crise organisationnel c'est à
dire que effectivement on vit dans une
société d'organisation la plupart de
notre vie se situe dans des
organisations est donc la meilleure
façon ou la moins pire des façon qu'on a
de répondre à ces crimes c'est une
manière organisée avec des organisations
dans lequel deux collectifs de soignants
de collectifs de pompiers entre l'
agence régionale de santé et la
préfecture entre les ministères donc il
est toujours très très intéressant de
regarder comment se comportent les
différents ensembles organisationnel qui
sont censées répondre à ces crises au
notre constat est que
la réponse française a été une réponse
qui a mis en exergue un certain nombre
de choses formidables comme la
coopération l'hôpital mais aussi des
choses beaucoup plus compliquées comme
la coopération entre le gouvernement et
les ministères entre ministères entre
ministères représentation locale de
l'état entre les représentations locales
de l'état par exemple les ars les
préfectures et les forces élective
notamment les régions et les
municipalités
et de ce point de vue là effectivement
je pense qu'on a beaucoup de leçons à
des slovaques une date qu'on a tous
retenus qui sera dans les livres
d'histoire c'est celle du 17 mars
le 17 mars le président de la république
nous annonce qu'on va être confiné mais
il y en a une plus importante en fait
quand on lit votre livre c'est celle du
12 mars
c'est le 12 mars que le conseil
consciente ific présente à emmanuel
macron les modalités à sion mais
thématique alarmante de l'impérial
college et même de l'institut pasteur et
c'est le 12 mars que nos dirigeants
réalise qu'on n'a pas de stock de
masques dits de tests ni les tests
nécessaires aisée enfin
c'est le 12 mars que emmanuel bach rohff
et son célèbre discours à la télévision
sur le fait que nous sommes en guerre
contre un ennemi invisible on né le 12
mars
et c'est seulement le 17 mars que l'on
va confiné mais on est quand même le 12
mars et on se dit ça aurait pu être
beaucoup plus tôt on aurait pu on aurait
dû mettre en place d'autres plan
pandémie contre la grippe toute chose
qu'on avait prévu ça ne s'est pas
produit alors évidemment je vous propose
de partir à partir de de ce 12 mars le
moment où nos dirigeants en fait panique
1 d'après ce que vous racontez dans
votre livre et on s'aperçoit qu'avant
cette date là la confiance régnait en
fait
en dépit de ce qu'on voyait de chez en
chine de ce qu'on voyait en italie la
confiance régnait et il faut l'expliquer
cette confiance ce que vous faites dans
le livre pourquoi est-ce qu'on était si
confiant alors pour le dire pour le dire
comme le montrent nos recherches on a on
a on n'a pas pu établir très clairement
quand les autorités se sont rendues
compte effectivement qu'elle ne
disposait pas des instruments classiques
de la santé publique notamment les tests
des masques pour prévenir la survenue
massive de cette épidémie pour prévenir
sa croissance exponentielle mais on sait
que c'est arrivé relativement
tardivement et comme vous dites pendant
un certain temps on a confiance alors
pourquoi on a conscience
la première chose c'est que on parle de
ce qu'on appelle un risque scélérat donc
c'est un concept qui a été inventée
francs par françois dedieu quand il
analyse la tempête de 1999 souvenez-vous
météo france
repère une formation massive de nuages
au dessus de l'atlantique en hiver quoi
de plus normal elle va arriver on lance
des alertes de routine et de suivi qui
sont classiques chez météo france met
mais personne ne s'attend finalement à
ce que cette tempête soit aussi violente
et ça va provoquer un nombre de dégâts
de la désorganisation aussi un nombre de
dégâts très importants en france risque
scélérat c'est donc quoi c'est
finalement
un risque pour lequel on se prépare pour
lequel on se prépare bien voir pour
lequel on sûr réagi mais qui ne se
produit jamais avec une amplitude qu'on
a imaginé et c'est vrai que avec les
différentes épidémies han1 leu leu leu
leu leu leu sarce avec tantôt on va trop
loin quand on veut passer loin et
finalement quand au début de cette année
2020 les premiers signaux apparaissent
on se dit qu'on est encore dans une
situation classique est une situation
d'une épidémie qui finalement ne va pas
avoir l'ampleur qu'on colle donc ça
c'est la première région juste vous un
terreau pour qu'on se souvienne bien
alors effectivement il y avait hier
épidémie de sras en 2003 puis h5n1 a
h1n1 mersque vide mais c'est surtout en
on s'en souvient qu on a eu l'impression
d'en avoir trop fait à l'époque roselyne
bachelot était était était ministre de
la santé
vous n'avez beaucoup de vaccins et on
est tout le monde s'était y en a trop
fait en fait on n'a rien on en est là on
allait rester là dessus quand on en a
trop fait il faut faire un petit peu
moins quoi exactement
alors soit soit ont commandé à
l'épidémie n'a pas été aussi forte que
prévu et quand elle s'est quand même un
peu installé en france on a beaucoup
trop fait donc c'est vrai que le risque
épidémique n'est pas un risque considéré
comme un risque très menaçants dans les
élites politiques ça c'est le premier
point il a été remplacé dans les plans
de prévisions par le risque terroriste
c'est un deuxième point très important
et un troisième point c'est qu'il faut
se rappeler dans quelle séquence
politique on se trouve
le gouvernement s'est trouvé confronté
au gilet jaune
il ya eu ensuite les manifestations
massives contre la réforme des retraites
et cette réforme des retraites n'est pas
du tout une réforme anecdotique dans
l'agenda politique elle est peut-être la
réforme sur lequel le président bak roux
espère être jugé à l'avenir et il veut
la faire passer quelques jours avant la
période que vous décrivez qui a été le
point de départ de votre intervention
on organise un conseil des ministres qui
est officiellement dédié à la gestion de
la crise du coc vide
mais en fait c'est surtout un conseil de
ministres qui va donner l'autorisation
au gouvernement d'utiliser le 49-3 donc
il n'est pas facile de sonner le tocsin
notamment les agences sanitaires
notamment les élites médical de sonner
le tocsin pour dire à un gouvernement
qui est tout entier tendu vers le
passage d'une réforme politique à la
valeur politique et symbolique
considérable que peut-être son projet ne
va pas se réaliser d'autant que souvenez
vous également un bon dernier point nous
avons le premier tour des élections
municipales qui s'annonce est là aussi
emmanuel macron est dans une séquence
politique difficile beaucoup lui
reprochent le caractère jupitérien de sa
de sa présidence beaucoup lui reprochent
de court circuiter les corps
intermédiaires de ne pas dialoguer avec
la société il ne va pas être en plus
celui qui pour une épidémie guerre qui
s'annonce va être le premier à annuler
des élections qui sont un moment de la
vie démocratique absolument essentiel du
pays mais vous vous expliquez bien
d'ailleurs que c'est pas facile
d'arrêter tout un processus
administratif démocratique
là les élections elles ont lieu le
premier tour des élections municipales
aient lieu le 15 mars
on l'a dit le 12 mars ça y est nos
dirigeants ont compris que de toute
façon ça va être signé une table il va
falloir si on veut juguler cette
épidémie va falloir confiné et pourtant
le 15 mars
il appelle à aller voter en fait même
s'il avait voulu l'arrêter à ce
moment-là vous dit que c'était pas
forcément possible et qu'on l'a vu dans
d'autres crises organisationnel
précédente
oui alors ce qui se passe pour ses
relectures heureuse aujourd'hui je pense
que le maintien des élections étaient
une volonté politique forte du
gouvernement à ce moment là il était
très important symboliquement de ne pas
être le premier ministre de l'année le
premier gouvernement de la vème
république à suspendre la tenue de ce
moment absolument crucial à partir du 12
mars en fait suite au week-end du 8 10
mars où il ya vraiment l'épidémie prend
vraiment de son ampleur dans dans le
pays
les informations que possèdent le
conseil scientifique donc le premier
ministre le ministre de la santé et le
président de la
publics sont des informations qui nous
viennent directement de la salpêtrière
et de bichat qui sont deux hôpitaux de
référence époque là vers lesquels on
envoie les cas les plus graves
donc les prévisions de listeria le
collège combiné à ces informations
cliniques ou au téléphone et on dit on
est submergé il ya des jeunes n'y a pas
simplement que les personnes âgées avec
des comorbidités c'est vraiment
terrifiant nos services de réanimation
sont déjà complets tout ça va contribuer
effectivement à rendre inéluctable
le confinement parce qu'on n'a pas les
autres instruments de la santé publique
et notamment on n'a pas lu masque qui
aurait pu certainement peut-être changé
la donne sur cette décision absolument
crucial et puis il ya pas de l'italie
non justement
arrêtons nous à un moment parce qu'il ya
vous l'avez dit on était préparé
le risque était identifié il y avait eu
des épidémies précédentes on avait un
plan de pandémie grippale élaboré en
mise à jour jusqu'en 2011 et jusque là
on est prêts on est prêt or ceux là ont
le nez plus près on va pas pouvoir le le
l'activé ce plan pandémie grippale
qu'est ce qui s'est passé là aussi
qu'est ce qui fait que la ja crise
organisationnel flagrante puisque on
s'aperçoit le gouvernement s'aperçoit un
moment qu en fait y'a pas de masque ya
pas de test et il le croyait il croyait
qu'ils en avaient alors bon sens elle
explique dans le bras je peux pas je
peux pas le thé un regard très précis
sur l'ensemble de ses processus
historique mais grosso modo dans notre
ouvrage on montre comment pendant toute
la décennie 2010 grosso modo toute une
série de décisions liées à la gestion
des stades des stocks de masques et
notamment la distinction entre stocks
stratégiques et stocke tac tic toc
stocks stratégiques
géré par l'état des stocks tactique géré
par les acteurs locaux va contribuer à
brouiller les responsabilités sur cette
gestion de stock
et puis aussi il faut le dire c'est pas
la menace la plus importante on n'y
croit pas à l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir
une pandémie on a eu on a été échaudés
comme je vous le disais encore tout à
l'heure on a été échaudés par des débuts
de menaces mais qui ne se sont jamais
réalisées donc effectivement on n'a pas
les masques on n'a pas les tests pour
d'autres raisons
sur lequel je reviendrai si vous voulez
même si notre investigation est encore
au cours sur ce sujet compliqué et donc
eh bien on se dit qu'on ne va pas réussi
enfin on se dit que au moment où on doit
prendre la décision on ne peut pas faire
autrement que de décider pour le
confinement éventuellement n'eût pu
décider d'un confinement qui était un
confinement peut-être plus régionalisés
mais en france vous savez on n'aime pas
rompre l'égalité par rapport à des biens
publics comme la sécurité sanitaire
donc on pouvait pas dire à tout le monde
vous allez être confiné à tel endroit et
pas confiné un tel autre souvenez vous
également que roselyne bachelot en 2009
alors que les modèles épidémiologiques
montrait qu' on avait il suffisait de
vacciner un certain pourcentage de la
population française c'était suffisant
pour atteindre le niveau d' humilité
collective elle a préféré décidé de
vacciner tout le monde parce que
l'argument qui est que certains peuvent
être vaccinés et pas d'autres est un
argument in entendable dans un pays
d'égalitarisme force mais comme l'est la
france et résultat personne n'était allé
se faire vacciner c'est là où on s'est
dit bon on en avait peut-être fait un
peu trop alors justement revenons
revenons au cas italien et la chine les
deux cas qui nous ont précédés qu'on a
eu sous les yeux à la télévision
à partir du moment où on n'a pas de quoi
déclencher notre plan pandémie anti
pandémie grippale on n'a pas les masques
on n'a pas les tests on peut pas faire
comme la corée du sud comme taïwan comme
le hong kong comme comme le japon on
peut pas espérer contrôler l'épidémie et
qui est très très peu de morts comme ça
a été le cas dans ces pays d'asie donc
on va probablement être dans le même cas
que la chine mais surtout que l'italie
or on les a sous les yeux et on ne fait
rien on attend on attend on attend on se
pense jusqu'au bout que ça ne nous
arrivera pas alors oui c'est vrai alors
ça c'est un autre point que j'ai pas
encore abordé ces quêtes
bon d'abord sais pas si vous le souvenez
mais alors il faut voir que la plus la
plupart des spécialistes et on peut
encore le retrouver sur internet moi je
regardais un thread note d'un
spécialiste sur twitter qui date à peu
près du 25 janvier de l'année dernière
donc il ya un an pile poil et vraiment
on sent que l'idée que les hôpitaux
français puissent être submergé fait
partie d'un scénario absolument pas
probable donc on a confiance dans le
système français
on a confiance dans les hôpitaux
français et c'est vrai que la médecine
de réanimation anesthésie réanimation et
la réanimation médicale qui sont deux
spécialités différentes empreintes sont
vraiment de notoriété mondiale 1 donc on
a confiance dans le système français
puis ya aussi trois clusters qu'on
arrive à résoudre il ya le cluster des
constats mines il ya un cluster en
bretagne donc sur la fois j'ai envie de
dire des époques passées où ça s'est pas
réalisée et puis de cette conscience
dans le système français est de ces
clusters qu'on a maîtrisé on se dit que
et puis aussi une rupture sage à 6 c
simultanément à cette envie de regarder
la réforme des retraites et les
élections et bien où on n'est pas trop
inquiet on n'est pas trop inquiet et est
en fait les premiers qui vont être écrit
ce soir est justement les réanimateurs
médicaux eux dans leurs hôpitaux ils
commencent à avoir déjà ils ont des
contacts avec leurs homologues chinois
parce qu'il préfère avoir des contacts
directs avec leurs homologues chinois
plutôt que de regarder les journaux
qui sont entrés tres tres review quand
vous savez on à ce moment là on publie
très vite et c'est après que le
processus de reviewing un peu sérieux va
être fait ils leur font pas très
confiance mais ils ont quand même
quelques informations directes avec
leurs copines chinois et leurs copains
chinois commencent alors des attentions
notamment d'ailleurs on leur donne des
consignes d'intubation c'est une mesure
sur lequel on reviendra plus tard et
maintenant on à tubes beaucoup plus tard
et leurs médecins italiens sont aussi
très réputé ils voient que la
réanimation médicale italienne est très
réputé et c'est vraiment j'ai envie de
dire à partir de la mi-février et plus
plus vraisemblable du vin ferait que nos
anesthésistes nos infectiologues nos
virologue français eux commencent à
comprendre que la situation va devenir
terrifiante parce que même si
l'anesthésique d'alien notamment
lombardi est submergé c'est qu'on risque
d'avoir aussi des problèmes en france et
il ya le moment où il ya le cluster de
mulhouse lui celui là on n'arrive pas à
juguler un celui-là ça c'est une date
importante aussi oui alors le cluster de
mulhouse ou si vous voulez quand on
regarde maintenant la façon dont il ya
eu des réactions comparative entre les
pays on se rend compte que l'ia des
mesures dans la gestion de l'épidémie il
ya des mesures qui relèvent directement
de cette politique anti épidémique et
puis il ya des éléments qui sont alliés
à la chance ou à la ma chance et
d'autres éléments qui sont liés à des
facteurs qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
politique de gestion de crise par
exemple en allemagne on pense plus
une des raisons certaines des raisons
qui permettent d'expliquer que
l'allemagne a connu une première vague
un peu moins sévère qu'en france c'est
notamment le fait que les villes sont
moins denses c'est le fait également
qu'il ya un taux d'habitation par
personne seule plus importante celle son
souci qui a un maillage avec des offices
locaux de santé qui est beaucoup plus
fort qu'on peut avoir
et puis c'est le fait qu'ils n'ont pas
connue comme en france un cluster à
mulhouse je pense que le cluster à
mulhouse vous le mettez dans n'importe
quel pays du monde sacré un
potentiellement une embolisation de des
hôpitaux aux alentours il ya vraiment ce
facteur j'ai envie de dire
alors je vais pas dire malchance je sais
pas si c'est un terme si on titille
confie-t-il divisé en tout cas la france
a connu plus tôt que les autres
un événement majeur de diffusion du
virus sur son territoire et puis il ya
ces modélisations mathématiques très
très alarmante qui circulent auxquels
d'après ce que vous racontez dans le
livre le président de la république est
confronté le 12 mars
ces modélisations mathématiques
aujourd'hui certains disent oui alors
c'était totalement délirant nous propose
nous nous promettait 300 ou 400 mille
morts
on les a pas eues à oui on les a pas
eues parce qu on a confiné
si on n'avait pas confiné on les aurait
probablement eu mais justement et en l
expansion la croissance exponentielle
d'une épidémie comme celle ci on sait
bien que l'un le fait qu on confine huit
jours plus tôt huit jours plus tard ça
change tout on a eu trente mille morts
pendant la première vague
si on avait confiné huit jours ou dix
jours plus tôt on aurait peut-être eu
que trois mille et si on avait confiné
huit jours ou dix jours plus tard on en
aurait eu vraisemblablement 300 milles
alors je n'ai pas les compétences
scientifiques pour parfaitement évaluer
la fiabilité de ces de ses modèles ce
que je peux dire en tout cas c'est que
tout début mars quand une première
réunion d'experts s'organise à l'elysée
personne ne porte le masque et les
prévisions de l'impérial collège sont
présentés et tout le monde est un peu
j'ai envie de dire distant ou critique
par rapport à ses prévisions
l'impérial collège dans le milieu des
épidémiologistes est paraît-il connu
pour être spécialement alarmiste et on
ne prend pas vraiment en considération
et surtout avec lui le sérieux qu'elle
mérite ses premières estimations
quand elles reviennent ces mêmes
estimations
quelques jours plus tard avec en plus
des éléments cliniques qui remonte de la
plupart des hôpitaux tout d'un coup
elles prennent un j'ai envie de dire une
nouvelle capacité de conviction et c'est
pour ça aussi qu'on a parlé de panique
des élites c'est que tout d'un coup on
se retrouve
le président son premier ministre et son
ministre de la santé se retrouve en face
d'un conseiller scientifique à une
grande asymétrique connaissant ce
conseil scientifique qui lui disent ça
va être un carnage et donc de ce point
de vue là effectivement la décision du
confinement bien nécessaire il ya juste
un point frédéric sur lequel je voudrais
revenir
vous dites on n'a pas activé le plan de
pandémie grippale alors nous il ya eu
des premières alertes et il y a eu un
système j'ai envie de dire de suivi de
l'épidémie qui a été très tôt mis en
place dès le début janvier on est dans
la routine classique on active un
certain nombre de mesures de
surveillance de vigilance au sein du
ministère de la santé pour le suivi très
sérieux de cet équidé de ce point de vue
là on a cru mais on n'active pas le plan
que tel mais ni grippal ont fait
l'hypothèse pour la raison principale
que le plan de pandémie grippale ça
oblige à mettre dans le jeu
un organe qui a été prévu pour la
gestion de ce type de crise qui est la
cellule interministérielle de crise et
la cellule interministérielle de crise
elle fait remonter à la table des
discussions et la décision à l'ensemble
des agences de ministères dont le
ministère de l'intérieur que
certainement emmanuel macron edouard
philippe et olivier ferrand ne voulait
pas voir rentrer dans le jeu de la
discussion et là on a quelque chose qui
est certainement l'expression et la
manifestation de d'un mode de
fonctionnement de de ce gouvernement qui
se méfie de ces administrations
la tempête qui a eu lieu deux ans
auparavant a été très mal gérée dans les
îles a été très mal gérée par la
sécurité civile il ya beaucoup de
reproches qu'on ferme notamment par
rapport la sécurité civile qui dépend du
ministère de l'intérieur et nous on y
voit vraiment la volonté pour le
président le premier ministre et le
ministre de la santé de s'octroyer une
capacité de décision autonome sans avoir
à faire monter à la table des
négociations
des agences des administrations qui ont
leur intérêt leur culture qui parfois
sont en conflit entre elles donc de ce
point de vue là il ya vraiment eu une
gestion qu'on pourrait dire élitaire des
grandes décisions de l'accident mais en
même temps et on va en parler plus
longuement après la pause mais
en même temps à ce moment là on va créer
c'est le 10 mars en qu'on manquerait le
conseil scientifique est là pour la
première fois on va s'abriter derrière
la science pour justifier des décisions
de politique ça n'était encore jamais
arrivé ça donc on veut être autonome
mais en même temps on a on a besoin de
la science à ce moment là vous avez
parfaitement raison c'est tout à fait
juste c'est-à-dire comment bien je pense
que nous faisons l'hypothèse que le
geste d' emmanuel macron qui consiste
emmanuel macron et de son équipe qui
consiste à créer un conseil scientifique
c'est un geste qui vise justement à se
ménager une capacité de décision
autonome d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose
qui on a déjà trouvé dans l'histoire
qu'elle est dit là mes frères on sait
que bernard cazeneuve au moment des
attentats 2015 secret ce qu'il appelle
aussi le fumoir c'est que vous reprend
vous créez comment dire un comité
d'experts qui ne représente que leur
personne et qui ne représentent pas des
administrations et on pense qu'on va
être tout son autonomie pour discuter
mais en fait ce conseil scientifique
comme je le disais il est il appelé
porteur d'une expertise
il sait des choses qui fait que le
gouvernement est très dépendant de son
avis est donc en croyant devenir
autonomes finalement se lient les mains
avec des experts particuliers qui ont
une expertise beaucoup plus importante
que celle et sait pas quelle forme de
panique 2 me j'ai envie de dire de
l'état ce moment là c'est tout d'un coup
ya panique quand on n'arrive plus à
faire sens d'une situation et ce sens il
est apporté par ce conseil scientifique
en disant ça va être un carnage
protégeons les hôpitaux et de ce point
de vue là quand vous dites c'est la
science qui dicte la décision politique
je pense effectivement qu'on peut dire
de ce point de vue là que la science a
été décisive dans la formation des
décisions politiques du gouvernement et
pas n'importe quel sens c'est une
science biomédicale
ce sont des médecins universitaires
parisiens ce n'est pas la santé publique
ce n'est pas l'économie ce n'est pas
tout notre série de science qui ont des
regards sur d'autres types de
conséquences de ce type de pandémie ont
fait une pause henri bergeron se
retrouve juste après on continue de
parler de votre livre tout à fait
passionnant
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec le sociologue
henri bergeron directeur de recherche au
cnrs à et qu'olivier borras patrick
castel et françois dedieu il publie que
8,19 une crise organisationnel aux
presses de sciences po
alors là parce que ceux d'autres
s'aperçoit plutôt vous nous le fait
remarquer en dans votre livre mais on
l'a bien senti c'est que tout à coup le
conseil scientifique qu'on a créé donc
très tardivement 1 le 10 mars se
superpose à à toute sorte de comité qui
existent déjà dont il prend la place de
des comités qui vont se plus ou moins se
concurrencer on est une espèce de deux
mille feuilles là que michel crozier
avait déjà analysé et qu'il avait appelé
un cercle vicieux bureaucratique c'était
en 1965 donc là aussi ça n'est pas
inédit 1
on a déjà connu ça et mais là ça va
atteindre des sommets pendant la crise
du corps d'un virus oui alors tout à
fait c'est d'ailleurs ça a été l'un de
nos points de départ dans la volonté
d'enquêter sur cette gestion d'un point
de départ c'était mais mais mais mais
pourquoi créton autant de structures
pourquoi investis sont autant de
ressources intellectuelles financière
pourquoi créton des plans des procédures
d'urgence si ce n'est pour ne pas les
activés pour ne pas les mobiliser au
moment où ces crises se réalise en
danger donc ça a été vraiment notre
point de départ
effectivement le conseil scientifique
est une structure ad-hoc qu'il est prévu
par aucun plan aucune loi qui va
d'ailleurs être rétroactivement
officialisé avec la loi d'urgence
sanitaire et à sa suite va vont être
créé toute une série de au conseil de
comité alors on va avoir le caire on va
avoir la mission castex pour le
déconfinement va voir la mission lizurey
pour l'évaluation de la coordination
interministérielle toutes sortes de
structures vont être mobilisés et crée
alors ce qui est étonnant c'est que le
champ de la santé et ses glaces santé
publique c'est pas comme ça partout
c'est pas forcément comme ça dans
l'agriculture c'est pas forcément comme
ça dans l'enseignement supérieur
l'emploi les finances publiques c'est un
chant qui est saturé l'organisation d'
expertise vous avez un organisme dédié
kevin scène vous a levé 4 ou 5 agences
sanitaires vous avez des au conseil vous
avez plusieurs ordres des médecins des
pharmaciens
vous avez des sociétés savantes enfin
j'ai envie de dire c'est vraiment un
endroit où on est très équipée ans ou en
institution experte et en plus des
institutions experte qui ont déployé des
méthodologies pour prendre des décisions
en situation d'incertitude les médecins
qui travaillent sur le cancer ça fait
longtemps qu'ils ont des guides de
bonnes pratiques pour les guider les
aider dans leurs jambes devant leurs
réunions pluridisciplinaires apprendre
décisions des décisions à situation
d'incertitude et là rien est mobilisé
alors comment on a voulu interpréter ça
on l'a interprété comme on vous l'a dit
tout à l'heure comme je vous l'aï dit
tout à l'heure dans une volonté
d'autonomisation puis le deuxième point
c'est celui que vous soulignez c'est que
y'a aussi c'est un geste technocratique
extrêmement traditionnel c'est qu'ils
ont ce qu'on considère que pour
améliorer la coordination et la
coopération entre acteurs qui est
absolument nécessaire en situation de
crise et il suffit de créer des
structures de coordination là où on a
des défauts une guerre entre le
ministère de l'intérieur et le ministère
de la santé pour l'appropriation de la
gestion crise comme c'est souvent le cas
eh bien on va créer une nouvelle
structure qui est sensé de leur
permettre une meilleure coopération donc
on va créer le centre la cellule atta
mills dalle de clichés pas ou souvenez
mais au mois de juin à peu près elle se
transforme en centre interministériel de
crise
donc ça c'est un geste technocratique un
canton quand on pense que ça va parce
coordonnées et ben on crée de nouvelles
institutions et on se donne jamais les
moyens de réfléchir à la façon dont
concrètement ces institutions peuvent
coopérer entre elles
et ça va se reproduire au bas mot du des
confirmands au moment du des confirmands
vous dites qu'il ya cinq structures qui
sont chargés parallèlement nude et
confinement alors c'est dans à
l'intérieur du centre interministériel
de crise il ya toute une série de
dessous dessous cellule
vous avez bien sûr l'addition castex
dans chacun des ministères des cellules
de crise sont elles mêmes activé au
niveau local c'est vrai que on passe
d'une gestion élitaire de la crise
alors quand je dis élitaire c'est pas
élitiste c'est à dire un petit nombre de
personnes le conseil scientifique et le
triumvirat de membres du gouvernement
président premier ministre ministre de
la santé à une gestion qui est beaucoup
plus multipolaire
chaque ministère a repris un petit peu d
j'ai envie de dire le dossier à sa main
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
de l'éducation chacun communique
j'ai envie de dire dans de manière
beaucoup plus autonome et puis quand
revient la seconde phase
donc là plus récemment on repasse à une
gestion élitaire alors cette fois c'est
plus conseil scientifique qui a été qui
a critiqué souvent d'ailleurs des
attitudes du gouvernement qui était
beaucoup moins dépendants qu'au début
mais c'est le conseil de défense
sanitaire qui est encore celui qui
aujourd'hui nous gouvernent donc ce que
si cette crise
elle signe une forme de méfiance par
rapport aux administrations health in ce
geste technique de création de
structures en lieu et place des
structures existantes quand on ne sait
pas les améliorer et puis elle signe un
gouvernement proprement politique de la
crise parce que ce sont vraiment les
élites politiques qui au prix les
décisions et qui prennent des décisions
les plus importantes pour notre pays
alors regardons du côté des hôpitaux
maintenant puisque vous leur accordez
évidemment beaucoup d'importance dans ce
livre première chose que vous remarquez
c'est que les hôpitaux n'ont pas
sous-estimer le danger ils sont là
depuis le début
dès que depuis qu'on parle du canal
virus ils sont attentifs vous l'avez dit
ils sont très souvent en lien avec leurs
collègues chinois
et ensuite quand quand tu es à la
panique de nos dirigeants quand on se
rend compte que les hôpitaux vont être
saturé on pourrait croire qu'on va
observer dans les hôpitaux français là
aussi plus qu'une crise organisationnel
un effondrement organisationnel or cette
eau fondremand n'a pas lieu
oui alors cette histoire ce concept
d'effondrement organisationnelle est
souvent utilisée dans la littérature de
science politique et sociologie des
crises justement pour insister sur le
fait que passa une situation terrifiante
et incertaine des organisations
s'effondrent elles ne savent plus
fonctionner il ya une dislocation les
gens ne travaillent plus les gens
éventuellement quittent leur poste et on
n'a pas du tout ça à l'hôpital alors la
situation des hôpitaux d'abord est très
contrastée parce que vous avez ceux qui
ont été vraiment en première ligne dans
le grand test dans l'oise puis il ya eu
ce coup lui un peu plus bien sûr les
centres de référence parisien en seine
saint denis
et puis ensuite il ya eu ceux qui auront
eu à monter en charge avec une dizaine
ou une quinzaine de jours de répit et
qu'ils ont pu se préparer alors les
hôpitaux
bien sûr sont très vigilants pour
beaucoup d'entre eux dans les entretiens
qu on a fait ça reste quand même
abstrait mais on a le plan blanc va être
un signal assez fort 2 attention
mobilisez-vous alors pouvoir que le plan
blanc c'est un plan qui vise à permettre
aux hôpitaux de s'organiser pour des
réponses aiguë c'est à dire quand
survient par exemple un accident de la
route avec un autobus où tout d'un coup
il ya un afflux massif de victimes
ou quand on earth un attentat justement
il n'est pas le plan blanc il n'est pas
fait pour répondre à une crise
épidémique géant veut dire qu'il se
produise donc ça renvoie encore une fois
de plus à ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure sur le fait que le risque
terroriste est à risque dans l'esprit
des autorités publiques a supplanté en
rire archi le risque épidémique mais
dans les hôpitaux on est très à l'écouté
notamment maintenant dans les service de
virologie dans les services de
réanimation médicale et et on commence à
s'organiser et nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est que on a vu beaucoup de
coopération de la même façon qu'on n'a
pas vu beaucoup de coopération au niveau
de l'état et au niveau des régions même
s'il ya d'autres endroits où il ya eu
des choses incroyables qui se sont
tassées on s'est beaucoup
on s'est dit mais comment se fait-il
l'hôpital est pourtant un lieu de
compétition de conflit c'est pas du tout
le lieu en temps normal où tout le monde
se serre la main quelles sont les
conditions qui nous permettent
d'expliquer pourquoi les soignants ont
réussi à coopérer notamment deux types
de soignants qui sont les réanimateurs
médicaux et les anesthésistes
réanimateurs qui en temps normal se font
gentiment la guéguerre sur les
ressources sur la renommer sur les
publications même s'ils n'ont pas
exactement le même métier et à la ils
ont le plus souvent même s'il ya eu
quelques frottements travailler main
dans la main y compris avec les autres
services et on a voulu comprendre
pourquoi et comment
pourquoi c'est important parce que
répondre à une crise c'est le plus
souvent répondre collectivement une
crise rien de grand ne se fait sans
coopération et donc si vous comprenez
les déterminants de la coopération si
vous comprenez pourquoi dans certains
endroits la coopération c'est fait et je
pense qu'on a donné des explications si
vous voulez on pourrait y revenir
eh bien on se donne des moyens de
reproduire à l'avenir ce type de
situation pour favoriser la coopération
entre acteurs
on voit notamment et ça a été dit avant
avant votre livre que tout à coup ce
sont les soignants qui ont repris le
pouvoir à l'hôpital qui n'était plus
qu'à 7 et les gestionnaires qui avait le
pouvoir
il semblerait d'ailleurs que depuis les
gestionnaires ont repris le pouvoir
mais pendant cette période là
il a qualifié de parenthèse enchantée
mais ce serait de mauvais goût puisque
ce une période particulièrement tragique
pendant cette période particulièrement
tragiques les soignants reprennent le
pouvoir alors c'est certainement la
partie de nos analyses où on a le plus
d'éléments pierrick on a fait beaucoup
d'interviews dans les hôpitaux auprès de
médecins auprès de cadres de santé
auprès d'hygiéniste et c'est là où on a
le plus de données est effectivement
l'explication principale qui était donné
dans la presse pour land des soignants
c'était ce sens éthique ce sens du
dévouement pour le patient et on n'était
pas satisfait par cette explication
c'est passé médecin qu'on applaudissait
tous les soirs bien sûr ils ont un code
de déontologie est un engagement qui est
absolument formidable c'est dur net
médecin c'est dur d'être médecin dans
les conditions de l'hôpital public
français actuellement notamment pour des
questions matérielles mais ça ne
suffisait pas parce que même quand ils
sont n'est pas en situation de crise ils
doivent soigner une passion et pourtant
ils sont souvent aux compétitions de
commandes explique qu'il n'était pas en
compétition d'art trou et on a trouvé
quatre conditions la première condition
celle que vous venez de préciser c'est
que le management de la ligne
managériale a fait comme on dit en
anglais enzo c'est-à-dire à laisser les
soignants s'organise
première condition deuxième condition
c'est la traduction au niveau de
l'hôpital du quoi qu'il en coûte du
président de la république et de ce
fameux discours
quoi qu'il en coûte et donc on n'avait
pas dix j'ai pas envie de dire que
l'argent coulait à flot mais quand on
avait besoin d'un nouveau matériel ou
pouvez le demander pour peu que la
demande soit raisonnable et raisonnée
troisième condition qui est une
condition très importante c'est qu'il
n'y a pas eu ça peut être vous choquer
ce que je vais dire mais de compétition
autour de la captation de patients dans
les hôpitaux avoir les bons patients
beaucoup de travaux de sciences humaines
et sociales montre ça c'est quelque
chose de rare et d'important et là il ya
eu tellement de passion que j'ai envie
de dire tout le monde a pu exercer le
soin sur les patients comme il le
souhaitait j'attire votre attention
frédéric sur le fait ça ça a été très
troublant dans les interviews assez
souvent nous a dit ça a été la pire
période de ma vie et ça a été
meilleure période de ma vie c'est à dire
qu'il ya un sentiment ambigu ou pas
ambiguë mais complexe hybrides chez les
patients ou à la fois ils ont vu les
choses terribles
ils ont beaucoup pleuré ils se sont
éreintés au travail et puis d'un autre
côté ils ont eu l'impression d'exercer
leur métier comme jamais et pour l
exercer et d'être vraiment utile et se
réaliser aussi professionnellement je
pense que c'est assez humain comme type
de cohabitation de sentiments et que
c'est pas du tout quelque chose qu'il
faut le leur reprocher et dernière
condition je m'arrêterai là c'est que
avec l'activation du plan blanc vous
suspendez l'ensemble des interventions
et ça ça signifie quoi c'est que vous
suspendez l'ensemble des enjeux
professionnels spécifiques à chacune des
spécialités de l'hôpital c'est un peu
comme si vous disiez dans une
organisation vous arrêtez tous de
travailler sur vos sujets on travaille
tous sur le même sujet où les gens du
marketing ou les gens de la finance où
je sais pas h et rp france on disait bas
les gens du service société les gens du
service et que depuis les gens du
service sport vous travaillez plus sur
le sujet nous travailler que sur un seul
sujet on redonne tout l'argent vous
organisez exactement comme vous voulez
vous avez autant de temps dans tel que
vous voulez y aura pas de compétition
eh bien vous créer les conditions de la
coopérative effectivement ce que vous ce
que vous ce dont la conclusion à
laquelle vous arrivez dans ce livre une
des conclusions c'est que au fond de la
bureaucratie française donne l'illusion
qu'elle peut à elle seule assurer la
protection de la population ce serait sa
faiblesse au fond et c'est ce qui
donnerait la depuis le début de la crise
vue qu'ovide c'est la crise
organisationnel que vous décrivez oui
alors ça je pense que c'est un poids
tout à fait essentielle et qui est aussi
une des explications certainement de la
défiance et de la déception que peuvent
ressentir les français par rapport aux
autres aux autorités publiques et par
rapport aux 6 aussi à la science c'est à
dire qu' il ya quelque chose de
typiquement français ou retrouve et en
allemagne
un peu moins en angleterre qui est que
l'état doit manifester sa fonction
régalienne de sécurité publique et de
sécurité sanitaire avec force
et le fait que l'état revendique depuis
très longtemps
ça a été confirmé par une jurisprudence
nombreuses importantes et cohérente dans
le temps qu'il est celui qui va gérer la
crise et ben place le place dans une
situation j'ai envie tenir deux dents
dans une situation de chroniques des
chacals ans c'est parce que quand vous
revendiquer haut et fort la
responsabilité de la protection face à
des menaces qui sont des menaces aussi
complexe aussi 10 yeuse on l'a dit un
forum pour le virus que celle là va
forcément il ya un moment où votre
gestion va pêcher et le fait que ça
pêche ça crée de la déception donc c'est
vrai qu'en france il ya une
revendication du monopole de la gestion
de crise par l'état et je pense que ça
met en situation de faiblesse si l'état
parce que ça le masa le met en situation
de qu'on lui reproche des échecs
en allemagne angela merkel de toute
façon elle n'a pas la main sur la mise
en oeuvre des politiques de santé elle
appartient aux länder de qu'elle est
obligée de négocier avec eux et quelque
part ça la met dans une situation qui
est certainement beaucoup plus favorable
d'un point de vue des sondages et de la
confiance
vous vous montrez bien à quel point
l'état s'est piégé lui-même au fond avec
avec cette crise du cornet virus
avant le confinement pendant le
confinement votre livre s'arrête au fond
au confinement votre et enquêtes
s'arrête au confinement on a pris cette
décision parce qu'on était obligé de la
prendre on en avait plus d'autre on
aurait peut-être plus sans doute pu
apprendre plus tôt toujours est il qu'on
l'a prise là et voilà pourquoi on l'a
prise là c'est le sujet de votre livre
mais on pourra dire que l'état s'est de
nouveau piégé lui-même il n'a pas tiré
les leçons de ce qui s'est passé puisque
à la fois avec pendant leur confinement
ils sous-estiment totalement le risque
d'une deuxième vague on arrive à la
deuxième vague que beaucoup de médecins
de scientifiques d'épidémiologistes
avait prévu la plupart même quasiment
tous l'état arrive en septembre et et
improvise totalement ce second
confinement beaucoup plus souple qui va
devenir rapidement une usine à gaz et
qui va faire que le pays ait qualifié
assez rapidement d'absurde is temps donc
il serront piégée à ce moment là il sera
piège au moment de la campagne de
vaccination
il concocte une campagne de vaccination
très lente
et puis quand il s'aperçoit à quel point
les landes par rapport aux autres pays
européens
il décide de l'accélérer mais c'est trop
tard et puis en ce moment même on
connaît le dilemme du gouvernement entre
face aux variants britanniques ou
sud-africains reconfirme en stricte
immédiat le plus tôt possible disent les
épidémiologistes depuis un mois
maintenant et le gouvernement temporise
espère
pouvoir s'en passer que le couvre-feu
fera son oeuvre qu'on va pas être obligé
de refermer tout parce que ça coûte très
très cher et puis ça coûte aussi l'image
que vous avez choisi pour ouvrir cette
émission c'est à dire du désespoir
ça aussi ça tue à plus ou moins long
terme
nous on a l'impression que tout s'est
reproduit exactement de la même manière
alors je serais peut-être pas aussi
sévère dans votre jugement que vous ne
pouvez l'être je pense qu'effectivement
on n'a pas eu de véritable opération
menée par l'état de retour d'expérience
alors on a eu les deux commissions
parlementaires
on sait ce que ce que valent ces
commissions parlementaires elles ont
tendance à singulariser la crise a dit
recettes exceptionnelles et elles vont
tendance soit à vouloir faire des
coupables individuel soit a pointé des
défaillances organisationnelles ou des
défaillances technologique
nous on est vraiment pour un système de
retour d'expérience où l'on se met tout
de suite à chaud comme on a pu le faire
dans les conditions d'observation pour
pouvoir capitaliser là dessus pour les
autres les autres crises et c'est vrai
que le mélange et je suis vraiment en
attente le comment dire le rapport du
général lizurey qui est sorti en en juin
que j'ai pu me procurer et dont les
conclusions sont assez convergentes avec
nos propres conclusions
on n'y a pas donné suite il ya une
mission qui s'appelle la mission pittet
du nom du professeur suisse qui l'a qui
va elle aussi qui a été activée veine
qui a été décidé par le président de
république qui devrait sortir bientôt
j'ai hâte de voir ses conclusions mais
c'est vrai que il n'y a pas beaucoup de
retours d'expérience et c'est vrai
qu'avec le deuxième confinement on a eu
l'impression du même degré
d'improvisation de la mise en oeuvre
aussi de mesures comme le couvre-feu
dont on n'avait pas beaucoup d'éléments
pour estimer dans l'efficacité
je rappelle que quand on met en place le
confinement il ya très peu de travaux
scientifiques qui ont évalué les points
positifs et les points négatifs et que
deux chez certains comment bien
scientifique ça reste une mesure comme
vous le dites préhistorique avec
beaucoup d'effets d'effets négatifs
alors là où moi j'ai l'impression qu' un
certain nombre de leçons qui ont été
tirés justement d'abord sur la sur la
surnature sur la stratégie de
vaccination alors j'ai pas et après je
reviendrai sur eux sur un visage sur la
stratégie de vaccination d'état n'a pas
cherché à amis mais ce qui se faisait
dans les autres pays
au contraire il a essayé de tenir il me
semble compte de la spécificité de la
situation française avec un niveau
d'hésitation vaccinale
alors parmi les hésitants vous avez des
gens qui se posent des questions
j'ai envie de dire de bon aloi par
rapport à la vaccination qui se posaient
des questions
et puis vous avez un autre qu'on appelle
les antilles vax dont certains une
espèce de nébuleuse qui n'est pas du
tout intégrée et cohérente
mais il a fallu tenir compte de ça je
pense que les tasses à a
seddik en y allant prudemment et bien
c'était une façon de construire ce lien
de confiance qui est un lien de
confiance très érodé pour les raisons
que j'ai mentionné auparavant
là où il a pêché pour la stratégie de
vaccination c'est que finalement il a
reproduit
comment dire un tropisme technocratique
français là encore que je n'ai pas
encore mentionné qui est celui de
séparer la pensée de la stratégie de la
pensée de la mise en oeuvre c'est ce qui
ce sur quoi se valorisent les élites
françaises
et c'est aussi comme ça dans les grandes
entreprises c'est de penser la stratégie
de penser la loi de penser le beau texte
et puis ensuite l'intendance suivra et
qu'on la tendance ne suivent pas on dira
que l'intendance prendra on peut pas
faire de stratégie sans tenir compte des
conditions logistiques et
organisationnels dans lesquels elles
vont être mises en oeuvre
agir ce n'est pas possible et ça de ce
point de vue la roma ou six bus pour les
têtes on a décidé qu'on allait cherrad
une campagne absolument massif de tests
souvenez-vous en septembre alors que la
mise en oeuvre n'a peut-être pas été
assez pensé avec les premiers opérateurs
de ces tests qui étaient les
laboratoires et on a dû les queues
devant les laboratoires qu'on a vu donc
de ce point de vue là moi j'ai bien aimé
le fait que même si finalement il s'est
fait rattraper par la patrouille comme
vous l'avez dit évidemment il a
fédérer j'ai bien aimé qui tiennent
compte de la spécificité française
la dernière chose c'est ce confinement
et c'est ce dernier point il ya quelque
chose pour lequel enfin nous on est
content de lui que le gouvernement
tienne compte des conséquences
absolument massive de ces mesures
massives et ça va être terrible dans les
années à venir pour l'instant ça reste
abstrait mais vous dire y compris
politiques y compris politiques
maintenant je pense que c'est un sujet
absolument affolants
est-ce que je favorise les morts
d'aujourd'hui où je favorise les morts
de demain c'est un sujet je ne sais pas
si moi même je peux y répondre en
revanche je trouve qu'effectivement
l'état n'a pas du tout organisé de débat
démocratique autour de ce qui est
associé un sujet et un choix de société
dans ce que ça a de plus dramatique de
plus sérieux qu'on puisse envisager
on prépare une société terrible par les
coûts par les confinements autant
pendant la première vague il était très
difficile d'organiser une discussion
avec la société civile avec les
représentants des partis etc autant
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument faire maintenant d'ailleurs
ils ont tiré des leçons vous avez vu
qu'ils ont consulté les formations
parlementaires sur cette question du
confinement donc de ce point de vue là
il ya il me semble une petite
amélioration par rapport à la situation
qui pouvait exister il ya encore
quelques mois
néanmoins tout le monde insiste beaucoup
sur la concertation il a des reproches
principaux que l'on fait à ce
gouvernement mais à tous les
gouvernements français depuis l'origine
au moins depuis le 5ème république c2c
de ne pas aller vers la concertation
enfin on sait très bien ce que c'est la
concertation sur confinement or par
confinement on aurait autant d'avis
qu'il est imaginable et à la fin il
faudrait bien tranché rien ne dit qu'il
n'y a pas eu ces consultations
d'ailleurs mais est-ce qu'elles sont
vraiment de l'importance puisque à la
fin
enfin on sait très bien qu'il y aura des
gens d'avis très très diverses et qu'il
faudra bien prendre une mesure et ce
sera l'une ou l'autre nous a déçus une
question qui est souvent posée dans le
cadre de la démocratie participative
finalement quelle est la valeur de ces
contributions
moi je pense que de toute façon il est
important d'organiser ces contributions
justement pour saper le sentiment
négatif que les gens peuvent avoir
d'être pilotés d'en haut sans être
consultés après il faut être modeste par
rapport à ce que cette participation et
consultation peut avoir dans pareille
situation historique mais je pense que
c'est c'est un devoir de discussion
démocratique qui de toute façon ne peut
pas faire de mal à notre à notre à notre
fonctionnement démocratique
et puisque l or justement c'est une
crise organisationnel enfin c'est
l'aspect crise organisationnel que vous
avez minutieusement étudié dans dans ce
livre avec l autre crise organisationnel
et ce qu'elle a le plus de points de
comparaison
à votre avis on a parlé katrina par
exemple sur le côté on ne sous-estimé
risque c'est comme dans par katrina par
exemple oui comme dans il ya il ya
beaucoup d'aspects sur lequel bon il ya
beaucoup d'aspects sur lesquelles elles
diffèrent il ya beaucoup d'aspects sur
lequel les similaire il ya des aspects
sur la crise des missiles de cuba dans
la prise de décisions qui sont qui sont
assez assez similaires et sur les jeux
de pouvoir qui existe dans ces comités
de prise de décision il ya des aspects
sur dans la tempête de 99 sur la
compétition au niveau local entre par
exemple salué la sécurité civile entre
entre les différentes administrations
locales qui là aussi qui va prendre la
main est ce que ça par exemple avec la
préfecture ou ou l'équivalent de la rs
donc il ya il ya plein de cris sur
lequel on peut trouver des aspects
similaire est là après des
caractéristiques absolument considérable
et notamment le fait qu'elle touche
toutes les franges de la société plus
durement certainement elle a des effets
très stratifié socialement rôle c'est
et que ricker est là elle est mondiale
donc de ce point de vue là ça fait quand
même une crise très particulière la
dimension organisationnelle c'est pas
juste une dimension c'est ça c'est un
point sur lequel je voudrais c'est pas
juste une dimension séguin on ne répond
pas à une crise sans action collective
et coopération donc c'est un ingrédient
absolument décisif mais tard qu'est ce
qu'il doit faire il doit apporter les
moyens matériels de gestion des crises
les vaccins les tests les masses mais il
doit aussi créer les conditions de la
coopération entre les acteurs qui vont
mettre en oeuvre ses politiques
et c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à
réfléchir sur les politiques publiques
et les politiques de gestion crise
uniquement sur cet aspect matériel des
techniques en se disant est ce qu'on
utilise en basque est ce qu'on aura
suffisamment de tests de ce qu'on aura
suffisamment de vaccins et qu'on
réfléchit pas assez sur la façon dont on
met en mouvement
cette distribution de masques cette
production de masques et la coopération
entre les acteurs qui concourent à
vacciner à protéger à se coordonner pour
apporter du secours
merci henri bergeron que 8,19 une crise
organisationnel vient de paraître aux
presses de sciences po
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
merci beaucoup
[Musique]